on va revenir sur l'affaire Palmade qui
est encore beaucoup fait parler cet été
avec une sortie très remarqué de
l'humoriste en boîte de nuit ou pas
est-ce qu'il y est allé ou pas alors ça
a été le gros sujet de cet été ce que
c'était bien lui oui non le directeur de
la discothèque sera avec nous dans un
instant petit récap regarde
le 10 février dernier l'humoriste Pierre
Palmade provoquait un grave accident de
la route sous l'emprise de stupéfiant ça
n'a été responsable en fait de prendre
la drogue aller sur la route plusieurs
mois après le drame l'homme mise en
examen pour homicide involontaire et qui
était hospitalisé au CHU de Bordeaux au
service d'addictologie venait de voir
son contrôle judiciaire s'alléger lui
permettant de sortir librement et cet
été le comédien aurait été aperçu dans
une boîte de nuit bordelaise en train de
s'amuser dans le carré VIP
[Musique]
si ces vidéos ont immédiatement fait
scandale et ont été visionnés plusieurs
millions de fois beaucoup doutes de la
véracité de ces images malgré les
témoignages et indique qu'elles sont
fausses alors Pierre Palmade est-il
vraiment allé en boîte de nuit cet été
les révélations exclusives du directeur
de la discothèque ce soir dans TPMP
Julien colonnat est avec nous directeur
d'exploitation d'une discothèque à
Bordeaux salut Julien salut ça va bien
merci d'être là en tout cas c'est Cyril
tu es vraiment un amour bravo merci
bravo pour tout j'aime beaucoup alors
cette histoire est folle parce que c'est
vrai que tout le monde en a parlé déjà
la question que j'ai envie de vous poser
avant de de par la Julien est-ce que ça
vous dérange vraiment si Pierre Palma
est allé en discothèque ou pas Kelly moi
ça me dérange énormément j'ai hâte
d'avoir la réponse d'accord on va
l'avoir dans un instant positive je
donnerai mon avis bien sûr vraiment vous
ça vous dérange mais ça me dérange
énormément
ça c'est dérangeant parce qu'il y a
quand même une affaire qui est en cours
il a quand même fait d'un gris et là on
apprend qu'il est en boîte qu'il est
complètement bourré que fort peut-être
qu'il a pris encore des stupéfiants en
boîte de ce que j'ai entendu moi ça me
dérange franchement mais je peux même
pas penser que de lui-même être dans une
sauce comme ça il s'amuse à aller danser
dans sa tête il faut être complètement
exploiter
pour moi c'est un sombre crétin il fait
ça si il fait ça c'est très bien
je veux dire il y a un moment donné
le secrétant dans la rue tu vas voir ça
va être gentil non mais c'est sur des
choses abominales comme il a fait lui
dans tous les cases
de Julien bon sens on a de
l'intelligence et peut-être que ça
drogue lui a cramé les neurones mais
c'est hyper excuse-moi qui trouve pas ça
choquant qui sont en boîte voilà non
Valérie moi ça me dérange pas qu'il soit
en boîte simplement effectivement c'est
juste débile parce qu'il sait très bien
que de toute façon a l'air des portables
etc non il y aura forcément la question
est-ce que c'est pas ça la question se
base est-ce que il a le droit d'aller en
boîte ou pas il a le droit d'y aller oui
aller mais c'est mal c'est le droit non
non il allait en bois
on parle pas de la loi on dit selon nous
la morale
c'est la morale pour moi pour moi mais
c'est un peu la même chose que le
prisonnier tout à l'heure qui est avec
sa piscine c'est qu'à un moment donné il
y a des règles tu as aussi le droit
quand même de prendre un petit peu de
bon temps
il a Jacques ça le choc pas non ça me
choque pas il suit il suit des soins
actuellement il a terrible ce qu'il a
fait c'est horrible il est pas excusable
il a dit lui-même
voilà donc pourtant il aurait pas dû
attendre un petit peu pour la décence
envers la famille de se comporter de
manière discrète
tout est une tragédie c'est
insupportable de le voir lui en train de
faire le mondial dans boîte de nuit
en plus juste pour le conducteur qui
était en face absolument mais maintenant
on parle juste de la boîte de nuit il
est autorisé par le juge oui bah il sort
il a le droit de le faire rien ne
l'interdit après moralement moi
personnellement ça me choque vraiment le
problème c'est la justice en fait alors
dès le début parce que s'il est en boîte
là c'est parce que la justice lui a dit
oui tu as droit d'aller en boîte la
justice lui a dit oui tu as droit de
conduire sous stupéfiant oui tu as droit
de cartonner une voiture en face de toi
et tu es un bébé qui était dans le
ventre de sa maman oui tu as le droit
oui reprendre des stupéfiants reprends
de l'alcool nous on peut le droit pour
l'instant on va savoir s'il est talent
ou pas mais parce que comme ça fait un
hypothèse énorme ce qui était Windir ça
te dérange pas bien sûr que ça me
dérange et c'est surtout que
c'est Michel hein c'est bien ça c'est
Julien ah bon
Michel c'est mon cousin
[Rires]
l'esprit de conscience c'est loup à ce
moment-là vous qui êtes patron de boîte
vous savez que ça fait énormément de
bruit
il est pas responsable non non mais on
est bien d'accord je vais finirai tu
verras qu'il sera toujours pas
responsable
pour le pour le coup quand vous voyez
arriver ce monsieur est-ce que vous avez
pas avec les leaders en disant vous vous
rentrez pas attendez pour l'instant on
n'est pas là il va nous dire s'il est
allé ou pas si ça vous dérange vous si
vraiment il est allé en boîte de nuit
oui il y a la loi il a le droit l'esprit
de la loi moi je trouve que c'est
dégueulasse en fait il y a un truc de
provocation d'impunité je fais ce que je
veux comme je veux j'emmerde tout le
monde il était au bout du rouleau il
s'est dit ses potes l'ont chauffé ils
l'ont dit il faut que tu sortes
ça veut dire que pour moi alors à ce
moment-là c'est encore un esprit très
malade et très perturbé il doit pas
il pète pas la forme suffisamment pour
aller en boîte alors Pascal moi je suis
d'accord avec Géraldine c'est un
problème d'abord d'image c'est l'image
que envoyer maintenant avec les réseaux
mais je pense que Pierre ils sont
totalement
ils sont fous totalement l'image là je
vais te dire je pense que là il a pas
pensé avait été allégé il avait le droit
hein pas de conduire pas de rentrer en
contact avec les victimes pas drogue
évidemment mais il y avait le droit
d'aller en boîte mais c'est vrai que le
message envoyé
pour moi la décence et la morale c'est
qu'il n'aille pas en boîte il reste chez
lui il reste à l'hôpital ou alors chez
lui il ne sort pas il se montre pas en
public c'est indécent les victimes vont
mal elles se reconstruisent très
timidement j'ai eu leur avocat
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile pour
tous heureusement le conducteur est
sorti de l'hôpital mais c'est très dur
de se reconstruire non il n'a pas le
droit moralement d'aller en boîte allez
c'est après je vais vous donner la
réponse ainsi
tu as des gens il y a un bébé qui est
mort il y a des gens qui peuvent plus
danser pour le coup et lui il va danser
donc c'est c'est ça que je trouve moi
extrêmement choquant et hâte d'avoir la
réponse du Grand Schtroumpf
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors regardez la vidéo la vidéo qui a
circulé la boîte s'appelle l'ultra club
c'est la plus grande discothèque de
Bordeaux là où il est depuis qu'il a
quitté la région parisienne parce qu'il
est à Bordeaux il y a cette vidéo qui a
circulé est-ce qu'elle est récente ou
pas est-ce que c'était vrai pierre Palma
t'a dit qu'il était pas loin et
d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est ce qu'a dit
Julien également
[Musique]
alors Julien
[Rires]
boîte de nuit d'Ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
il nous en parlera après on s'occupera
de ton cas après je te remercie Julien
Julien donc Julia pierre et vous vous
avez dit qu'il était pas allé dans cette
boîte donc qu'est-ce qui parce que vous
avez dit qu'il était pas là que c'était
en fait c'était pas la c'était pas là
c'était pas pourtant c'était avant voilà
est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas alors
j'étais contacté dès le dimanche matin à
partir de 9h on débauche à 8h du matin
j'ai eu 98 appels de de tout ce qui est
journaliste tout ça bon moi la base je
suis à peu près la discrétion de mes
clients la première chose que j'ai dit
c'est qu'il était pas présent en
discothèque bien sûr parce que ouais bon
c'est arrêtez pas de t'appeler tu as dit
voilà moi je suis pas là j'ai pas le
balancer voilà et bon et je te dis je
comprends
je te jure Julien on t'appelle on dit le
gars ça se fait pas je veux dire
franchement à la limite je comprendre
que tu les fais je comprends que tu dis
qu'il y ait pas aller qui n'était pas
allé qui n'était pas allé parce que
franchement ça se fait pas tu aurais dit
oui à tout le monde oui il était là hier
soir et après donc tu étais obligé de
dire qu'il y était pas et tu sais Cyril
j'aurais dit j'aurais dit bah oui il
était là et tout on aurait dû faire le
buzz sur ça tu fais toi tu t'es mis un
souvent au milieu de de tous ces
déchaînements médiatique mais
moi je suis un commerçant 21 salariés
j'ai Monsieur Pierre Palma de quai de
Bordeaux qui était venu auparavant dans
la discothèque avant le ouais ouais
euh moi je il y a il y a le ministre de
la Justice comme ça il faut aller voir
notre ami
tu le connais je le connais oui bien sûr
qu'il y a une petite alors
Julien à 20h49
il est venu dans la boîte ouais il est
venu dans la boîte tu avais menti au
départ tu l'as couvert
mes clients il y a pas à savoir s'ils
étaient là c'était pas là donc elle
m'appelle un mec qui me dit ce que veut
prendre la parole lui il est outré que
il est il a bien fait de de le couvrir
une question
on t'a dit tout de suite il y a pas le
mal à l'entrée ou bien tu le savais pas
du tout moi j'étais devant d'accord
j'étais devant bah tu laisses rentrer à
toi de dire s'il doit aller en boîte ou
pas il a réglé sur l'entrée bah oui il a
réglé ses consoles bien sûr
pas le match tu l'as pas fait tu l'as
fait payer l'entrée
de l'alcool vous avez fait un cercle
avec lui vous avez posté un selfie avec
lui le dimanche puis vous l'avez retiré
donc là vous avez avouer des bêtises
parce que c'était une ancienne story
vous dit des bêtises c'est un
journaliste qui va vous êtes un
journaliste qui est très mal la première
fois qu'il est venu voilà tout à fait
voilà donc et toi la deuxième a été
rajouté c'est pas la même police de
texte il établi en blanc suivez vos
dossiers
il vient te le dire qu'il est venu donc
pourquoi il va te mentir
c'est incroyable c'est qu'il a menti
tout ce temps-là Cyril qui bah lui mais
il a le droit
ça fait ça fait des années que tu as
toute mon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a des journalistes qui l'appelle le
dimanche matin franchement moi j'aurais
pas aimé que Julien dise oui il était là
hier soir qui donne tous les détails il
a il l'a dit non au départ c'est normal
et puis là de sa symbole négatif pour
lui parce que ils ont dit ouais il a
menti il est venu il vient rétablir la
vérité je comprends tout à fait le mec
il se retrouve dans une sauce dans
laquelle il a rien à voir dès le départ
comme client m'appartient du moment où
vous l'acceptez c'est normal de pas le
dire je pouvais pas Madame
moi je suis un commerçant je lui dirai
quoi non et je cautionne pas ce qu'il a
fait il y a la famille et tout ça je
cautionne pas du tout ce qu'il a fait
Jacques le problème c'est que je voulais
demander s'il avait consommé ouais vous
avez il a consommé de l'alcool ou pas
deux vers l'alcool même pas la bouteille
rien il est au vif
après vous l'avez accompagné
je suis resté devant lui une voiture
je dis ça Cyril parce que pour le coup
judiciairement c'est intéressant si on
apprend ce soir qu'il a pris le volant
maintenant
dans un taxi
moi je considère que vous n'avez pas
menti je considère que vous l'avez
protégé je l'ai protégé je trouve ça
très bien comme je protégerai mes
clients c'est normal voilà donc Alex
good tu le protèges ah oui là merci
beaucoup
il l'a protégé c'est normal tout est
normal pierre Palma dis donc c'est
normal c'est normal il fait ce qu'il
veut stupéfiant c'est normal c'était ton
petit garçon de 5 ans qui sera resté
trois mois à l'hôpital tu auras dit
c'est normal que personne
dans le ventre de ta femme tu aurais dit
c'est normal que personne c'est normal
qu'il protège réponds-moi nettement mais
oui mais parce que vous êtes dans l'idée
que dans l'émotion dans cette mais oui
bien sûr est-ce que tu sais par être non
non mais je vais te répondre je vais te
répondre est-ce que tu sais que sa
notoriété
risque de lui coûter bien plus que s'il
avait été quelqu'un de l'inconnu pour
exactement les mêmes faits non mais
alors dans ce cas là on va vers une
justice où il y a une automaticité c'est
à dire que il a fait ce qu'il a fait et
ça coûte je sais pas moi 5 ans 6 ans 7
ans 8 ans aujourd'hui la justice elle
est à l'appréciation du juge et en
fonction de comment va se dérouler le
procès figure-toi que ça notoriété c'est
certain ça va lui coûter bien plus que
s'il avait pas été connu par exemple je
vais te dire par exemple est-ce que tu
sais que dans le cas d'un accident de
voiture il y a pas il y a jamais de
perquisition au domicile il a été
perquisitionné son domicile a été
pertiné il y a des éléments
matériels humains qui sont mis sur cette
affaire qui sont bien plus importants
que pour des faits similaires avec
quelqu'un qui n'est pas connu sans
compter les affabulations quand on a dit
qu'il était pédophile pour tenir ça jour
après voilà du tout avec un petit
d'entretien partout alors sa carrière
est terminée je veux dire évidemment et
encore une fois la victime c'est d'abord
le bébé
on est quand même d'une manche étude
incroyable envers Pierre Palmade et
qu'est-ce que tu as ben non mais
franchement je trouve que Jacques
cardotz là qu'est-ce qu'il a parce que
il défend les gens qui vont être jugés
pour potentiellement pour homicide des
blessures involontaires je les défaut
quand même pas du tout c'est vrai bah si
vous dites qu'il a le droit d'aller en
boîte que si comme ça
vous dites que ça notoriété va lui
causer bien des trous
c'est l'inverse tu sais pourquoi parce
que l'enquête l'enquête montre d'ores et
déjà Gilles l'enquête montre d'ores et
déjà que les moyens qui ont été mis en
place sont bien plus importants que si
c'était quelqu'un de par exemple
il y a eu une perquisition le lendemain
à son domicile toute la nuit etc non
mais ce sont des choses Julien il faut
dire un truc oui oui je veux dire je
voulais répondre à Raymond je n'ai pas
protégé je leur ai fait pour tout le
monde vraiment en fait que tu la protège
c'est ton métier c'est ton business il
vient n'importe qui vient le monde de la
nuit c'est le monde de la nuit ici on
fait comme on veut profiter PA qui vient
s'il vient c'est qu'il est en liberté il
est pas vu c'est pas sauvé d'une prison
il te demande la consommation d'alcool
il y a pas de problème
pourquoi les caméras de surveillance
elles sont sorties
alors ça a été pris dans l'entrée
de la discothèque alors il y a les
retours dans l'entrée de la discothèque
bon et donc là alors donc toi tu avais
dit au départ qu'il était jamais venu
voilà c'est totalement faux il n'était
pas chez nous ce weekend il est déjà
venu mais la vidéo date de l'Avent covid
depuis on a fait des travaux on peut
s'en rendre compte en comparant avec les
images qui ont été filmées tout à fait
mais tu nous dis aujourd'hui il est venu
il est venu et je voulais je voulais
dire aussi parce qu'il a que je me suis
verdais c'est la contacter l'avocate à
la famille mais
Pierre Palmade il a fait des des tests
d'urine dès le lendemain ou le lundi je
sais pas quoi et qui ont été révélés où
il y avait pas il y avait pas de drogue
dans dans le parce qu'il y avait comment
il s'appelle
Olivier
c'est moi de tout ça
d'accord ok merci à toi merci Julien
d'être venu et on t'enverra Alex Goude
dans la boîte